بعد عده سنوات من الاستقرار الامني ياتي
تفجير الدم في شارع الاستقلال في اسطنبول
ليعيده الى الاذهان سلسله اعتداءاتنا
استهدف التركيه لاسيما في عام 2016 و2017
في الاول من يناير كانون الثاني عام 2017
اطلق مهاجم مزود برشاش النار عشوائيا على
حشد من المحتفلين براس السنه في ملهى في
اسطنبول ما ادى لمقتل 39 شخصا وجرح 79
واتمنى الاعتداء تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
في العاشر من ديسمبر كانون الاول عام 2016
اسفل اعتداء مزدوج قرب ملعب عن 47 قتيلا و
160 جريحا وتبنته جماعه صقور حريه كردستان
القريبه من حزب العمال الكردستاني في ال
28 حزيران عام 2016 ثلاثه انتحاريين
يفتحون النار في مطار اتاتورك قبل تفجير
انفسهم ما اسفر عن 45 وعنا قتيلا
و163 جرحا ولم تتبنى اي جهه الاعتداء لكن
السلطات نسبته الى تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
في السابع من يونيو حزيران عام 2016 اسفل
اعتداء بسياره مفخخه في حرب يزيد في
اسطنبول عن مقتل 12 شخصا وشرح 36 اخرين
تبنته جماعه صقور حريه كردستان في ال 19
من مارس اذار عام 2016 اسفره هجوم
الانتحاري في شارع الاستقلال عن مقتل
اربعه سياح واصابه 39 اخرين ونسبته
السلطات الى تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه في
الثانيه عشر من كانون ثانيا عام 2016
فجرا انتحاري نفسه وسط مجموعه من السياح
في حي السلطان احمد ما اسفر عن مقتل 12
شخصا وجرح نحوي 15 اخرين السلطات نسبته
ايضا الى تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه